en lieu et place plus grand parc il y à
domicile et françois des marécages que
louis xiv fait assécher avant de faire
construire grands bassins et fontaines
deux fois par an l'effrontée n'y pénètre
dans les souterrains du caraquet finale
portions et brest mais gala des pires et
qui sont encore beaucoup plus basse que
ça il faut aller en rang et heureusement
ne va pas tous les jours 30 km de
canalisations free centenaire est
parfaitement conservé sans déconner de m
07 exactement avec des joints de plomb
ou à l'époque il n'y avait pas de pièce
qui permettait de faire des coups de
dons qui jouait sur l'épaisseur du plan
pour arriver à faire de la courbure on
aperçoit vraiment la forme de la boot
avec les conduites qui suivait la
perfection avec pas grand chose et tu
arrives là sortir des choses fabuleuses
qui ont fait de nous avec nos trois
cents ans d'expérience on arrive
évidemment avec des pièces aux autres
mais c'est on n'est pas leurs auteurs
à deux routes carrosse de ses jardins à
la française
le domaine de la rune entre note un
esprit champêtre
c'est le chef jardinier entretiens
peuvent en effet les maîtres façon un
peu demeure la web mode de leurs
chroniques
l'image que les gens ont de versailles
ce sont de magnifiques jardins à la
française ce sont des meubles de luxe
sont des tableaux de maîtres et d'un
seul coup nous les fenêtres et on voit
des meules de foin toute simple toute
bête et c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est ce
décalage entre le versailles deschamps
je dirais et le verset incroyable lasky
protocole de la cour marie antoinette
est en quête de liberté
et là où d'autres reines rêve de
nouveaux châteaux elle se fait
construire un simple à le
le jardinier qui m'a conçu s'est
comporté comme un véritable peut être en
fait ne l'a pas voulu imiter la nature
il l'a idéaliser le hameau de la reine
dans représente l'environnement notre
environnement non pas telle crise l'est
vraiment mais peut-être qu'on aimerait
qu'il soit et voici le lieu où
probablement le plus secret du domaine
la grotte de marie-antoinette la reine
mener ce conversation privée sur ce banc
il y aurait même moi je suis personne
quelquefois l'architecte a prévu
également une petite place pour
permettre de s'asseoir et d'observer par
le trou dans la paroi
c'est quelqu'un vient et c'est quelqu'un
vient et qu'on ne souhaite pas être vue
voire surpris eh bien on se sent floué
par l'escalier qui permet de sortir en
hauteur et c'est dans ce lieu un autre
nom 1789 on vient la prévenir de
l'arrivée des révolutionnaires
c'est le dernier majeur fait qu'il
l'aura vu
au bosquet appelée salle des balles les
fonds kenny règle maintenant la cie
mépris des chutes pays
on est en train de regarder si les
conduites qui alimente les effets de ne
sont pas bouchés
est on en train de regarder le de bidou
sur les lames qui ne sont pas parfaites
et or fait ou de droit net de matinée
j'ai tapé dix jours